okay we are back
live and we've got some stuff to
do I really want to do this uh this
hyper pram sweep stuff but I got a
couple things to do first I think
probably hyper pram sweeps are going to
be for
tomorrow we'll start on carbs tomorrow
what's today it Friday it is Friday so
we're going to start on I pram stuff
tomorrow um right now I need to
do I need to start on this other thing
here where's the paper this
thing this really shouldn't be that hard
to
and there shouldn't be that much to
change here to support
this I need to
add I need to add a buffer for a matrix
as
I think we're going to just do this
single
purpose so we we kind of just do this in
a branch and if it's good we'll add it
to the implementation if it's not we're
not we
won't all right
so
lstm state
experience this goes into experience
right and then this is going to
this e3b
Matrix or
them that seems weird to
me where's didn't
could have
broken I hope
not we were messing around with um Isaac
Jim and
stuff why is my why my overlays not work
I'll get the chat up
here
uh how's
it I thought I branched off 2.0
require okay I don't know what the [ __ ]
is up with this because this
this should be a fairly small
change I'm hopeful we can just get this
done
today and then I can start on hyper pram
stuff
okay puffer Li does not require three
points so I don't know what the hell's
up with this
on yeah okay
python yeah this is it it's I don't know
what the heck's going with
P also let me go check for status update
from
NYU no
updates I'm good with that
do what's what's up here it's still
going
okay so we're going to implement this
like this exploration bonus algorithm um
without the inverse Dynamics model to
start and see if it you know just see if
it does
anything okay so this now
lovely let's hope that we haven't
completely destroyed Ruda
drivers I can run this on the remote box
but I'd rather
size I guess you just make sure that it
actually has it
size
Co experience
map then we do
this now we have storage
and do we need to do anything with this
map I actually don't think we need to
give a damn about any of the other stuff
it's not used in the loss
function it's only used in the
reward yeah so I think we can just I
don't even think we need the do numpy
version I think literally we just need
E3 BM
here okay
and
yes and this just gets returned
basically as an extra State variable
mat inic I think this is what it is and
then what you have to do
is um where's
this
map and then you do e3b
mat
this
okay then same thing here
this and then all you have to do is you
have to
add uh you have to add the intrinsic
reward to the rewards so let me think
how to do
this
device
nid right because you could be getting
different nids
but the rewards we just add to I
think I think we just add to the rewards
so we do
reward plus equal in or reward like
this and then you have to
pass
E3 you have to get this
here like so
and actually this is has to be done uh
regardless of if you have an lstm or not
so this goes up
here okay and
then this goes
e3b E3
B cool and now this has to
get propagated into the
policy um
yeah this has to go into the
just so we make sure there's no
surprises
here I really wish my stream overlays
actually
folks okay so what we have to do here is
prop
we have to add
e3b to here this is going to be State
action uh and we'll just add
here
okay this 3 is
none X State
3B and this should be
good now this also returns inic
reward action value
State uh now this has to return us new
e3b new intrinsic
oops see yeah new
e3b and new intrinsic
reward so so this is now going to
return State
E3
this this is be an intrinsic reward now
this is fine this is this is now
correct and this is self. policy so then
we'll have to adjust that there let's do
the same thing over here
we add
e3b we add
e3b there's no state for this
one
ISB and now this is going to return an
additional e3b and intrinsic
reward course
e3b so now this is this is everything
for the clean RL binding
uh now we have to
modify our
models and I think that by default all
we
really need to do is modify our
recurrent rapper and our default would
be a good starting
point so lstm wrapper of
policy this needs to
take e3b
observations it's going to be in decode
actions that we use
e3b I'm using this is a nice time to get
rid of this look
up I think I'll leave it
though
so the thing with the lookup Ram is I
think you actually need it for
um I think you actually need it for
entity based models captain
I think you actually need it for entity
based
models maybe it should just be star like
qus or like qus or something I don't
know this is just on a separate Branch
anyways this makes such a mess of all
the policy code that this is only going
to end up getting merged to the main if
it's really
good isn't used yeah that's
fair we're going to end up adding it
back if we ever want to do entity
anything though I used it in the old
neur MMO
policies basically without it you don't
get to use the encode decode
API like the a the encode decode API
doesn't work if you don't have that or
entity base
models I mean I'm going to redo a bunch
of this policy stuff anyways at some
point it's just it's on the Queue of
stuff to do right
it's always a million things to do okay
so this should be enough for the lstm
rapper uh now I just want to add this to
the default
policy and this should be enough for us
to run
experiments once I know debug
everything oh actually hold on this
needs to
go forward yeah okay this goes into
decode and that's
fine all I have to do is I add it
here we just do
e3b n like
this and then here we're going to return
actions value e3b intrinsic rewards now
uh we have to actually compute this so
what we're going to do
is add the
equals
how do we do
exponential
decay oh I think it's just going to
be yeah it's literally
just um
equals then it has to get initialized to
something doesn't
I so it's Lambda I to start
with what's Lambda
I they give you
Lambda they said it was pretty robust to
Lambda
final value
.1 is what they
use so we'll just add 3B
and this
well I think we'll hard code it for now
it's a pain in the ass
so it's going to be
1 *
torch.
I hiden
okay right
here e3b next is going to
be
0.9
times
0.9 5 *
3B
[Music]
outer
plus
how do you like make a torch constant
that gets moved to
that seems pretty
good that seems pretty
e3b okay um
what are the odds that this
runs oops not this
one this
right not really it's just the batch
size it's
gigantic but wait you don't need these
in a batch do
you you don't need these in a batch you
need these
in you need number environments of these
okay so I have the storage from
all luckily
I guess this is just too
big I don't
know um
this still out of
memory I don't understand how this is
possibly out of memory
E3
B that
this there you
go default no e3b
expected okay so we just have to fix
some math here
128 so if you were to get rid of
these it would be
squeeze so it's 5
do
unze
this is GPT I'm it's screw this it's
been too long since I've done
this uh I
have a times
see
do
solve oh
interesting hey Joseph love your work
wondering if you have any suggestions
for more accessible projects for someone
new to RL looking to do some original
research uh for new RL people I always
recommend that you implement a simple uh
high performance environment yourself
end to end and uh get something training
on it this is what I've had like all the
new puffer contributors do you can pick
something that will have like
interesting science on it for sure but
that's what I would suggest give you an
idea of all these
environments I implemented neural MMO 3
MOA and snake obviously have code
reviewed and edited all the rest of them
but like the rest of these are all by
contributors that are mostly new to RL
um and like implemented these as a way
to get involved in it so anything as
simple as you know as simple as pong all
the way up to like you know this is a
more complex environment to implement so
is
go right any of
these as would be my suggestion
we have lots of examples like all the
code for those is open source and it's
fairly
simple I mean it's in C but it's very
very simple see
what are your thoughts on Lex Freedman I
have no thoughts on Lex Freedman I
haven't seen any of his
podcasts what are you trying to do
currently I am implementing
uh e3b or most of it which is a RL
exploration
algorithm and uh there's some funky math
that I'm looking at
then so restoring the inverse M I
guess can you give me a learning path
who wants to learn yeah I have a guide
on this on my ex it's also on the puffer
blog
here I have a very simple approach to
most things that I think you'll find
pretty accessible
um the stuff I do involves you know very
little math very little like complex
stuff to think about it's mostly just
getting the basics down and doing them
very very
well the best stuff in my toolkit is
honestly being able to write simple high
performance
code that ends up being more useful than
most other
things for new people I always just I
suggest like building an environment end
to end from scratch and contributing it
to puffer lib just go through that
process of building an end for puffer
and also training RL on it because you
get the process of like what goes into
making a brand new problem work with
reinforcement
learning it's the best thing you can do
and it can be done
in simple environment can be done in a
few days if even if you're brand new if
you just have decent software
engineering
are you a PhD student no I'm a grad I'm
graduated I'm a MIT PhD I finished up
last
puffer okay so I definitely want to
implement this this way
one over
Lambda this is
10 which is kind of
is buffer something like gymnasium no
because gymnasium is just an API for RL
environments um puffer is a lot more
than that so puffer has way higher
performance distributed simulation
compared to
gymnasia um we don't have as much API
overhead we have our own environments
that we have made that are like a
thousand times faster than basically
anything in
gymnasium uh we have high performance
training code gymnasium doesn't do
training we have ultra high performance
training code we have really nice
logging we have automated hyper
parameter sweeps puffer is the project
that I am building to make RL simple
fast and
easy it's everything you can see our
demo is on
puff. they'll run live in your browser
okay so I think this is good for
intrinsic reward and then we have to do
this
update to e3b which is going to
be e3b
what's the what's the most efficient way
to implement this
[Music]
this is
U one plus
this I think this is a [ __ ]
implementation that it just gave
me am I Frozen on
good welcome YouTube
folks what we are currently doing we're
implementing e3b which is an exploration
algorithm for
RL um and there's a little bit of fun
math here German
Morrison rank one
update and I'm just trying to make sure
I do this correctly and I do this the
most efficient way possible I think that
this is giving me garbage
because so C inverse U so this is
fine but
then compute the scaler
right CU this
is UT and yeah okay
so let's just let's just make a little
like
you let's do this
so return
CN what the heck is
that what
VT so we do this
and
then so that's now
CED and then we'll
do do
this I don't think this needs n
squeeze
CN minus
plus should I focus to solve problem or
anything else would be I I'm not sure
what you mean by that
like learning
algorithm you're going to get confused
if you just start doing like learning
algorithm ablations and stuff
immediately I generally think the best
way to get into reinforcement learning
is to go through the process of making a
new environment and then going through
the process of getting reinforcement
learning to solve that new simple
environment because that will teach you
um that shows you how to structure
observations how to get data through the
network you're probably going to have to
do a little bit of hyperparameter tuning
you're going to have to like understand
the process by which uh environment's
compute observations and rewards and
similar and and parse actions and all of
that so like that's kind of the whole
end to end thing there's very little on
the algorithm side of RL that really
matters like everyone loves to go
straight into all the fancy math and
algorithms like Po kind of just solves
everything if you do it right and yeah
that's kind of limiting and there are
some probably some things out there but
like 90% of the people in RL are just
spinning their wheels on algorithms
right now um I would way way way more
recommend just like going through the
process of making and fully solving a
problem building an M yeah so you're
going to build an environment and you're
going to solve it with reinforcement
learning so I would just I'd pick
something that is like relatively simple
you know people have done pong people
have done breakout right people have
done simple grid type environments so
pick like some simple little game that
you're going to have fun building
something that's going to only be a few
hundred lines of code you can do in like
a couple of days and you know then look
at our puffer examples look at how we've
built them and match that and then go
through the process know for your
environment of extracting and Computing
observations Computing
rewards uh getting data you know for
many parallel copies together into the
storage tensors
running training you know doing hypercam
optimization all of that that's what I
suggest it's a very good way to get
involved we've had people do this that
are you know brand new to reinforcement
learning you have Discord y discord.gg
puffer there are like 900 people in
there lots of helpful folks
well I mean this is all on our website
proper. we got GitHub Discord and X all
these
things you can see all of our uh you
know all of our environments here as
well if you just go to Ocean like you
can literally play all of these in your
browser and watch Agents play them so
like here this is an agent playing pong
RL agent playing pong in your browser
and if I hold shift if I hold a shift
then I take over and now I'm playing the
game for the agent right I'm taking over
the agent and now I take my hand off the
keyboard and it plays again and this
works with all of our environments you
can play around with they're all open
source they're all on the on the GitHub
pretty much they're all like one file
each very nice and self-contained
they're very very very
fast we make it very easy for people to
get onboarded
that's correct isn't
it e
okay that's pretty
good are you using multi-agent for pong
no pong is single agent um it's like the
original Atari game uh the opponent is
uh the opponent is a scripted bot we do
have multi-agent environments though
we've got lots of
them like uh here we use snake as
multi-agent each of these is an
independently controlled uh
independently
controlled the this will train in like 2
minutes on a one
GPU uh we've got neural MMO this is
massively
multi-agent tons of different things
this the scripted box you know these are
scripted but there are uh like 100 some
OD trained agents for
environment m is multi-agent each of
these is a different agent
and I think there a couple others like
rware and trash pickup are both
multi-agent so yeah we got lots of
multi-agent it's the exact same thing as
single agent except when you have like
highly competitive
environments it's not any harder with
puffer at
least I mean my PhD is in multi-agent
like many agent learning
oh hold on
um am I screwed here
because you don't need this at train
time it's already computed the rewards
you don't need it at train
so
here we
got entropy
value TM State we don't give a [ __ ]
about
this right we do not care
contains okay so
let's back up
table one over Lambda inverse
right but they say that their Lambda
is they got like a Lambda of
10 I don't see how that's
possible but that's what they say
Ridge regularizer is this a different
Lambda hyper parameters for
e3b and they do
possible yeah they got 01 everywhere
did they clip or
something I don't understand how this
thing
works because they're
they uh they have a different
formulation of it
is oh
message I'm a third year hold
on I'm a third-year college student I'll
be getting into a seventh month long
internship soon we have less workload
I've been thinking of learning
neim I still use my mouse a lot right
now it takes all of 10
minutes it really it takes all of 10
minutes
um here
this is my whole config here okay I got
super
Maven I got semi that's it I got two
plugins the rest of this stuff is just
um color theme this is just custom color
thing I got like a couple little options
set and that's
it that's literally it I don't do
anything fancy
I just stick this into uh my base Docker
container and then I have my whole my
whole work setup in a container wherever
I go it's
great so this is a clever little trick
that they have
um I think I can do outer b
b and then I can do divide by 1 +
B getting used to it I don't use that
many HJ K move around I use maybe like
10 shortcuts total I really don't do I I
mean there are people that get way way
fancier than I do I I use very simple
things
you'll honestly you'll be used to it
within a couple of
days I used um I used just like Vim with
no plugins for six 78 years I don't know
okay so let's see what's wrong with this
thing
I mean the questions if you want to get
into RL right like whatever editor is
whatever
fun at least it's fun now it used to not
be too much fun
so it's got to
be uh row so UNS squeeze so UNS squeeze
two un squeeze
one do you do freelance for work
assuming this is not a passion project
well I guess it kind of is puffer is a
company as well we sell we sell uh
support contracts to companies that are
doing RL and having a hard time of
it technically what I'm doing right now
is part of one of
those so all our stuff is free uh all of
our stuff is free in open source but uh
you know we sell we sell like support
priority service stuff starting 10K a
month for companies
we do it I do it for free for uh for
academic Labs so I've got like three
academic lab collaborations and you know
some
clients we're definitely looking to
expand puffer over the next few months I
mean this is only I've been doing this
since last spring it's less than a year
creative
idea yeah I mean it's like this is not
how I would monetize puffer if uh if
that were the primary goal but I think
that this is a perfectly good way to
revolutionize reinforcement learning and
I think it can be plenty profitable like
this as well the goal is really just to
have like a small to midsize uh industry
lab that's just turning out awesome RL
work
constantly we're well on our way I mean
puffer is probably the fastest growing
RL project out
there I don't know why I have these on
still I just left them on from my last
one should be UNS squeeze two UNS
squeeze one
okay now
really I'm
right or is
it but maybe that is correct
correct I'll just look and see how
problem solves favorite thing good luck
on your stream sure thing thank you
I mean stuff like this takes me forever
because like I don't mess around I like
I used to be pretty darn quick at this
stuff um when I was doing a lot of
architecture work but now it takes a
while but then if you like it when I'm
like going through a code basis and
fixing stuff it's like super super
fast some stuff's slow some stuff's fast
I still get everything done
and then what is
this maybe this is do squeeze maybe we
get rid of this do
squeeze B do
this the heck broke my
terminal broke my terminal
try
this hey there it
goes value
loss yeah
okay so this now
runs massively slows down the uh the
forward
pass cuz they're inverting a bloody
Matrix
here I mean this makes sense that this
is massive to me I don't know how it's
possible that they have Lambos what they
say
Implement cuz they say Lambda is 01 I
mean they say lambda's
0.1 so then Lambda
inverse is going to be the is 10 times
the identity Matrix and then they add 10
times the freaking identity Matrix to
every single
iteration so I don't see how that's
possible oh wait see yeah no they add 10
times the
just popping in to say I really enjoy
your work been following for a few years
thank
you we're currently implementing e3b
into puffer lip seeing if this
exploration algorithm does
anything my prediction is it's just
going to be too
slow um but there's some weird things
with
it this is for a client um the thing I
really want to do which I'm going to
probably do if I finish this soon I'll
I'll just start on that but um the next
thing I want to do is look at carbs and
really fix that hyper parameter tuning
algorithm that's going to be huge for
puffer and for RL
overall cuz I found some bugs with carbs
or some design issues rather with carbs
earlier today
how is this possible
like I'm going to just drop this PDF and
plaw and see like I don't expect
anything out of it but
like usually it's like a confirmation
that yes in fact you know this paper
like this is insane and it doesn't make
any
so adding
10x Matrix
is added
once not
accumulated
oh okay so yay Claud for once is
actually helpful I got it did I get it
wrong huh yeah I did get it wrong okay
me
stupid me very stupid
hey Captain finish some M optimization
now 170k training verse 130 very well
done very
good M speed is
everything M speed is everything I'm
interested to take a look at the
uh you know the way that box 2D handles
cuz apparently there is a tree you said
for
collisions yeah the rest is mainly box
2D so the question is basically going to
be when we strip down box 2D is there
anything we can find that's slow there
okay I actually don't know what the hell
an AABB tree is I don't know is
that I would think you would just want
like a quad tree or something or even
just like a fixed grid but I don't know
I I didn't even add this I and it's
still blowing
up it's fairly well optimized as
is don't know how much we'll be able to
speed it
interesting I mean the physics CS in
your environment though they don't seem
like they would be capped to 100 like
they don't seem that they would be
capped that
slow you're
handling like on average a sing single
digit number of moving
things
right yeah mental MTH doesn't check out
Captain there's got to be
redundancy if you had like thousands of
entities then sure but you
don't yeah and all we care about is the
average because you have enough parall L
that it's going to
[Music]
why is the value lost immediately
garbage
this okay the L definitely being screwed
up
by this Cal
okay so this is training a little bit
without the bonus
yeah so this learned something but it's
very slow
value loss is stable so then what
happens is you add this thing
on what if I do
0.01 maybe just need to be
scale now the value L immediately
freaking explodes
still not as badly but still it's
crazy 01 yeah no it's still
expe
um is it like on the graph or something
weird
exploding do they have a coefficient on
this thing or
something
B okay they do have this beta
to one
they set it to
one
exploded I imagine that
this this Decay is not the problem
right yeah that's way worse immediately
so and what do they do here they
[Music]
do they do this B
term 1 over 1+ this
at one over 1 plus
intrinsic and they
do this outer
and how can the value loss possibly be
that
big when the intrinsic reward should be
clipped let's go look at
so I don't really like the fact that I
have to clip
here I'd rather clip the iate M Rewards
right okay so let's try
this
next let's try this
next okay so the value loss is still
crazy but less
crazy yeah way less
crazy now is this sued or something
like why is the
value function like that
okay so break point
here can you move the puffer it's
blocking the
losses oh this guy yeah he likes to
block
losses we'll find a nice uh stream
overlay thing
soon I'm going to be streaming way more
flipped what the
heck well that'll do
it oh because it's it's uh it's
discounted returns is why okay so yeah
if you have one reward per step
value is going to
explode I don't understand how this
thing of theirs
works
thing let me think if it makes sense
that it's this
should be about a
m i can test real quick maybe this is
not an optimal config
right um we can
oh
interesting so how is that not what's
making it slow
that doesn't make sense to me
this oh that's
funny I guess it was the numpy is Nan
the bug
check okay so it does take a perfit a
pretty big perf hit
this I guess it's the really big values
that are the
problem clamp and then
scale oops
guess okay we will probably do that
let me commment this for
we need like a nice exploration
environment I'd like to have like a maze
or something for
me just send this over and then uh we'll
see what we do from here it's only five
okay so that's set
um let me see here
next
thing I'd like to go get myself some tea
or something but it's a little
late I think we're going to do hyper
pram stuff
next I need to get
myself woken up a little bit
and yeah so
so I know roughly what I want to do so
let me let me give you the outline real
quick and then um I will come back in a
few minutes and uh and start working on
it so there's this algorithm called
carbs from muu it's a really good
hyperparameter tuning algorithm it's
cost aware the goal is it launches a
bunch of fast experiments in order to
build up a good predictive model of what
hyperparameters are going to give you
what performance and then it launches
slower experiments over time that give
you higher per uh but I found some
issues with the way that it
samples uh parameters specifically that
prevent it
from essentially affect essentially
prevent it from exploring outside the
initial space of hyper parameters that
you give it very effectively so the code
base is very complex very overly complex
I'd say for what the algorithm is
and I'm probably going to go through and
try to simplify it and see if I can get
perf before and perf after uh to be you
know substantially better I have a
synthetic Benchmark that's really quick
to run and I'm probably going to play
around with that a little
bit that's going to be the goal I'm I'm
going to
have about an hour or so to do
this yeah I'm going to have about an
hour to do
this before dinner and then I'll
probably be back after as
well I'm going to go grab myself a drink
real quick take a couple minutes and
then we will uh we will get implementing
that and this should be pretty good
because this is uh this will be a major
major major thing for our
yeah I'll be right back don't let me
forget to unmute my
okay here's what we're doing
next well first of all I got to check to
make sure I don't
have anything missing because I was
expecting an update
from NYU
on their
stuff but they don't have it
now let's
see let me just check this on the side
real quick might have to do GPU Drive
stuff
depending okay didn't get to it cool
we get to do cool
stuff I have finished the log of work
for
today so we get to do cool stuff for a
little bit
deal here
is the
deal this is a synthetic
test the max score is like 2
50 carbs does not get
there some parameters it fits nicely
some parameters it completely
fails we're going to now look at
carbs
and uh look at some of the stuff that I
found earlier and see if we can fix some
things so
this is the generate candidate
function sample around origins in
basic Creo
groups so this is going to this samples
group okay and then right
here search distribution in
so there are
two two issues with this
fair issue number one is the way that
it is
converting hyper parameters into a
normalized
space that is not correct the way it is
doing
that issue number two is the way it is
sampling
around the hyper parameters in that
normalized
space let me think about how I want to
do
this it's very important that I get this
right
so we
got right here
others let's think about parameters in
log space first
this is what that parameter looks like
transforming into long space
interesting so you would actually like
to
transform your
space okay so I see why I'm not getting
this right now I have a transformation
into a good space for
sampling so what I do is I take log of
this right and then I do plus one for
instance and then you do 10 to this
and lo and behold you get
0.05 so if you take you take the log and
then let's say you grab some standard
noise
right you can see that this gives you
some good samples
right because the standard deviation of
one in log space is one order of
magnitude
and then there's a clip Factor so you
can prevent it from sampling crazy
things so it's going to go up to two
orders of magnitude in either direction
this is a very very good thing for
sampling
however this is not perfect yet for
fitting
parameters for
parameters you would like the entire
thing to be in the range
of let's say -1 to one or 0 to one
either
way so what does that transformation
look like
well I think it's just like you
subtract the
midpoint which is the
-2.3 and then you
probably just divide by two whatever
sample you
get and you
so do I make my
own version of
if I have my own version of this I can
make my own
algorithms to be fair carbs will
probably
though so pretty much I think carbs
actually has the
right they have the right API for this
their fun names kind of
suck but they're not that far
off so like if we look at their spaces
oops in
utils look at like log space or linear
space so they've got param from
basic which is if you give it a
value like a value of the hyper pram it
transforms it
into a nicely normal space now their
Transformations aren't correct but
that's the
idea and then if you get a sample from
from that
and then when they do dot
observe let me
observation see they convert it to basic
space again
repo like we don't really care about
this serialization stuff
model it's a giant ass
utils maybe 2,000 L total in this
repo I think we could get it to a
th000 the first thing I want to do is
figure how to fix it
though so maybe what I'll do is I'll
leave everything
alone but I'll fix their transformations
start I'll fix their
Transformations and I'll fix their the
way that they're sampling around their
transform
it oh you know
what I kind of see what they're trying
to do with this
me yeah no they're correct
so the idea is that all the samp are
normal
um see for a uniform space does this
make
sense it still kind of does make sense
right if you have some prior on like
what what the mean should be
okay so this should
be
that so that gets you
to to
this and
[Music]
then foram from
basic value is going to be equal
heck +
1 over 2
rounded
okay this rounds
and then they need to round operation in
basic which is kind of
weird do they use this round
tensor basic
kind of weird that they do
that I guess it's they want
the the
why don't we just
do
lules
Pam self. param from
Basic Value and then this round
right
through and then we do value
equals self. base from
and then we can do the same exact thing
here
center why don't we do search center
right
S search
center and then we
do
Dot and this is clip not scale
and you should never be able to sample
zero
works and then if it's rounded you round
and you
um even with their search ter this
actually should
work if I do it this
way it should work even with their
search term
value equal
1us value
ma.
log one minus
value
base base is 10
we shall see about
this that's zero to one scale still so
I'll have to fix that
and then there's never any rounding
here so you just return the value
clip and you add search
center you
take I'm getting really
tired this is stupid but I'm going to do
this
I'm going to hope I don't get bitten by
PPT failing something the simple
there we
go the one minus goes at the start
obviously just
cool
so this is
good where's our power
two P
two I thought I had a
this a new
container
right I think it's actually very similar
to the log space and it's scaling
wait I think it's just
this search center think of search
but it'll be
fun I
so I see so you do
value
mean is going to
be 2 to the
value the log 2
value minus mean
well this is supposed to be basic from
foram first of
times
and we're going to fix all this stuff up
later tonight just a prototype
value the round tensor in basic is just
going to be we get to eliminate all
these obnoxious functions
okay
so that's all of
them and all I have to
do is clean these up a
bit I actually don't like the way that
I've
specified
parameters I think I don't like the way
that I've specified
clip I think mean scale Min and Max are
going to
be the parameters
work the way they use scale is currently
confusing yes it very much
is the thing is their stuff is wrong
Captain
um it's confusing because it's wrong
do the mean doesn't have to be
zero actually the mean can't be zero the
way I'm thinking about it
confusing it's kind of difficult to
explain this Stu I'm thinking about at
the moment but basically I'm trying to
figure out a good space to transform I'm
basically trying to figure out how I
want to parameterize each hyperparameter
and then what latent space I want to
transform them into that's going to be
good for learning a predictive model as
well as for
parameter actually let's go even simple
let's say that we have a uniform
parameter as a min
a
Max and a
mean the mean is not exactly between the
Min and the
max so that means we want a sample
around the mean and we want to get
values from the Min to the
max how do you transform that
parameter easiest would just be to
rescale it between1 and one
then what you would do is you'd
search you would sample from the surf
Center doesn't have to be zero that's
fine you'd have a
scale parameter
and we'll think about how the scale pram
works but it like you can have a scale
pram so you sample normal distribution
around
that you clip to Min and
I think I know how to do
that
so me and men and Max are
obvious what about scale
distribution
three it scills pretty
good I mean it kind of
depends on the
good might not even need a scale
parameter with this
need you might need it for something
like total time
okay I got to go I'll be back in uh like
an hour